I'm at the heart of katara's cultural
Village
[Music]
heading to guitar Studios
[Music]
Studio responsible for these
for the FIFA World Cup cutter 2022
remember to always spread love and be
yourself
[Music]
and now they faced two more challenges
the opening and closing Ceremonies for
which we had a sneak preview
and that's all we can play because so
much of what they're creating here can't
yet be revealed
one of the projects I'm working for this
FIFA is uh medeles
which means I have to join different
music together like a piece of puzzles
last few months is in is in my head all
the time
what can I do what can I make it better
is this really happening or what can I
do what else I can add it what else I
can contribute
the music for The World Cup is something
that we're really proud of
it's a product that is being listened by
many many fans around the world you have
also the official mascot of the World
Cup Larry which is you know you can call
him a Qatari product
Tara's Studios will go into their big
match in good form having produced the
official music videos and World Cup
mascot live we decided to go with sort
of a Pixar route since it is a animated
cartoon character type feel and we
wanted a very modern Pixar sort of
feeling when we approached the music but
with little elements of Arabic music
traditional music Arabic instruments
it all takes time to build but the
effect should be quite magnificent
maybe 60 70 80 piece Orchestra as
actually well as working with male
choirs female choirs sometimes together
sometimes in separate sections then
building those layers so that we get in
production values like the sound of 200
voice 200 piece choir
Katara Studios is responsible for the
official World Cup songs and they shared
these moments from the making of the
music videos
and fans from around the world will have
to tune in to the opening ceremony and
see how it all comes together
Laura Khan Al Jazeera Katara Doha